[tense music]
Nuri is one of the most
intensive concentrations
of pyramids anywhere
in the world,
across any culture
and civilization.
[upbeat music]
In Sudan, in fact, there are
more pyramids than in Egypt.
And this is
something that people
don't think of very often.
NARRATOR: Kush and Egypt
have a long interwoven
history, one that
is just beginning
to be more fully understood.
FEMALE: Most of what we
know in the history books
about the kingdom of Kush
comes from the perspective
of the Egyptians, because
the Egyptians had writing.
And the Egyptians wrote
everything down, everything.
They pushed a phenomenal
amount of paper,
we would say in today's world.
And we are fortunate to
have a lot of those records,
but those records frame
everyone outside of Egypt
as somehow not equal
to or lesser than.
History is written
by the victors, the 1%.
And archaeology tells the
story of the underdogs,
of the other 99%.
The best way to really verify or
disqualify a historical account
is to look for the
facts on the ground.
Sometimes it jives
with the history
books and sometimes it doesn't.
[tense music]
NARRATOR: Archaeologist
Geoff Emberling
has excavated many important
Kush monuments, uncovering
its past brick by brick.
GEOFF EMBERLING: We know that
from the very first moment
that Kush appears in
history, around 2000 BC,
it was powerful.
It was so powerful that the
Egyptians, at that time,
built a series of
fortresses along the Nile
to protect themselves against
the military power of Kush.
NARRATOR: From its prime
position on the Nile,
the Kush Empire control
trade routes from the south
up to Egypt, transporting
ivory, leopard skins,
precious stones, and gold.
GEOFF EMBERLING: They had the
connections with inner Africa
that could bring
these exotic products
all the way to Egypt and to
the wider Mediterranean world.
FEMALE: They were
the go betweens
and they became very, very
rich and powerful off being
in that position.
NARRATOR: Egypt
relied on Kushite gold
for their elaborate burials
and fierce Kushite warriors
to supplement Egyptian armies.
Eventually, the Kushites
gained so much power,
the Egyptians saw
them as a threat
and invaded their
neighbors to the south.
For the next 400 years, Kush
was controlled by Egypt.
In the beginning,
the Egyptians imposed
their gods and temples on Kush.
FEMALE: They were taking the
elites of Kushite society
and giving them
Egyptian educations.
NARRATOR: But the
Kushites, eventually,
became even more devout
spiritual followers
than their conquerors.
Even as the Egyptian
empire began
to lose strength and
withdraw in 1100 BC,
the Kushites continued
building their tombs
in the shapes of pyramids.
The jewelry found
inside the burials
makes clear their
devotion to Egyptian gods.
We know that by at
least, at the bare minimum,
by the 8th century BC,
Kush is on the rise.
They have thrown
off the shackles
of their Egyptian
colonizers, but they do
retain some Egyptian elements.
NARRATOR: For the
center of their kingdom,
the Kushites took over a place
full of spiritual significance
to the Egyptians, a stunning
sandstone butte rising
high above the desert
landscape, Jebal
Barkal, or sacred mountain.
From here, the Kush kings were
able to control an increasingly
extensive territory.
GEOFF EMBERLING: Ultimately,
that rise of power
led to the Kushites being
able to conquer all of Egypt,
and that's historically
just remarkable.
[upbeat music]
NARRATOR: For nearly
a hundred years,
a succession of five Kushite
kings ruled all of Egypt.
From Napata, their capital,
they controlled more area
than any other
Egyptian pharaohs,
stretching from modern day
Khartoum to the Mediterranean.
One of these Kushite
kings, a renowned warrior
named Taharqa, established
Nuri as a royal cemetery.
GEOFF EMBERLING: In many
ways Taharqa was the most
notable 25th dynasty king.
The cemetery that he
established at Nuri
became the royal burial ground
for Kush for over 300 years,
so he became the ancestor that
the succeeding kings of Kush
wanted to connect themselves to.
[tense music]
NARRATOR: Kings like Nastasen,
who Pierce Paul is hoping
may still lie inside his tomb.
I would like to find
evidence of Nastasen himself.
I'm not saying I want
to come up face-to-face
with him in the middle of the
third chamber in the dark,
but it'd be an experience.